[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien la peine de passer toute la
journée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le passé simple
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai peur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore Hugo j'adore un spectacle sur
les plages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va enchaîner tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque fois elle arrive de là-bas comme
une libellule
elle arrive
le Huc en arrière
on dirait qu'elle fait des brochettes tu
sais le lion en arrière comme un vas-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va faire Kelly et après les gars on a
un revenant
Nicolas pernica
prénom de chanteur Michael non Nicolas
pour ton retour d'audience donc
attention
[Applaudissements]
j'ai lu que la seule
la seule la seule qui ose me toucher
c'est Daniel quand même
non mais c'est vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]